have you ever had a game you've never
got around to playing for me that's
minecraft which came out 11 years ago
before this video I played a total of 42
minutes of Minecraft building a house in
which I forgot a roof I'm the epitome of
the word noob then I watched Luke the
notable and his 100 day series and
thought what could I learn in 100 days
without any help or guidance so sit your
butt down for half an hour go subscribe
to look the inaudible who founded this
format and let's see what a newcomer to
Minecraft can achieve in 100 days with
no help from anyone at all this is going
to be painful day 1 I awoke in my new
world after setting the seed to penny
thick yes I'm a fully grown adult and
I'm extremely immature in the distance I
noticed a mountain and decided that that
would be my home to celebrate I punched
the plantlife it took a long time to
arrive at my destination because at this
point I didn't know there was a run
button I quickly made a hobbit hole and
began to make a bachelor pad it wasn't
much but at least I had a campfire to
sing songs like a real Boy Scout at this
point I noticed the sounds of the
zombies nearby it's quite unnerving and
I waited for daybreak day to arrived I
gave myself a task of making glass
windows
I hope science class would help me here
so I grabbed sand from the beach whoo
what physics I wasted the rest of the
day trying to understand how to make
glass but don't worry I figured it out
let's not discuss how long that took me
day 3 I'm still making windows I'm new
to this don't judge me
day 4 I finished my window so I knocked
down a nearby hill to let more light in
and let the world see these pro-level
building skills damn I'm good day 5 was
my lumberjack day I spent the entire day
hitting trees I found it relaxing to be
honest I wasn't stressing out at all for
now
cancel that on the way home a size zero
Robin Hood decided to attack I ran away
and hid like the real man I am back home
I still didn't know how to make a bed so
I made a hat to pass the time I'm
gorgeous day six while afk in the night
a zombie dude got in I pretended to be a
statue until we fought I got the victory
in my first encounter
with a God Tyr opponent I spent the rest
of the day mining into the mountain to
block off any further attacks like that
day seven
I found iron ore this is important to
note because it's the only iron I find
in what feels like forever to celebrate
I made new shoes damn I'm a sexy
[ __ ] day eight I got completely
lost let's not talk about day eight on
day nine I made a storage box I
absolutely went insane when two of these
boxes became one big box it was my first
big brain moment on day ten it was time
to make a bedroom the sleepless night
were taking their toll on my pixelated
body I hunted down a sheep in the hopes
their world could keep me warm I made a
white bed I should have made a brown bed
for what was going to come in the next
few days on day 11 I had my first taste
of community life when a guy with Harry
Potter's llamas stood on my roof I tried
to steal the llamas but couldn't damn it
day 12 I found horses I was so happy I
couldn't contain myself I offered them
sapling and accidentally punch one in
the head I hope he forgives me later
that day I returned with an apple as a
token of my apology he loved it so I
jumped on his back and fell straight off
now here on day 13 I have been here
almost two weeks and I still don't know
how to farm today was the day that
changed leveling off the ground outside
my hobbit window allowing me to monitor
the crops all day and night genius I
thought what a pro I am I instantly
realized I couldn't plant anything so I
made a hoe and put her to work then I
spread my seed and waited day 14 was
pretty much the same I remember dropping
off with my hand covered in my own seed
I should have washed my hands so should
you
day 15 was here the day of my first ever
harvest and dammit I planted a tree
accidentally farming life ain't for me
well not yet anyway oh and in all the
commotion I forgot to show you my pet
chicken he's called Chuck and he has his
own pen I'm lonely alright day 16 is a
monumental day I found civilization I
followed a feral wolf into a new town i
timidly went inside expecting to be
mugged for my killer sneakers and
gangster hat but no they were great
people in fact I learned this day that
villagers are here to swap goods with I
now have a reason to hunt for leather
and
Tepper these green Zelda rupee things
are I also learned that jumping on crops
is possible and stealing other people's
crops is possible too you saw nothing
looking back on day 17 is painful I was
mining but at this point I had no idea
about how deep I needed to go to get the
best resources I can see now that I was
wasting my time but on day 17 I felt
like a legit adventurer I spent so long
in the depths of the mine I had no idea
what day was turns out it was day 18
I found a zombie child this day which
blew my puny mind I helped him escape
this purgatory and hoped his dad
wouldn't notice he did so I sent him to
meet his kid in the afterlife on my
third day straight in the mines I
finally found them all iron I was so
happy but immediately a skeleton
attacked me I was so confused I tried to
fortnight building walls to protect me
and then I attempted to crank a ninety
bad idea I died I was legitimately
gutted I thought that was the end of the
game but then I awoke I had chosen
survival mode and I couldn't have been
happier
my journey continued I spent the rest of
the day hunting down my equipment and
got lost again it was bound to happen
day 20 a Harry Potter llama guy returned
I noticed his llamas were not on lead to
this time so I stole them get out of
that pen Chuck I have real companionship
now one llama hated me so much he spat
all over my sweet sneakers in
retaliation I murdered their former
father I named them Luke and Leia in
homage to the real dark father day 21 I
finally realized I could use both of my
hands I told you I was a noob so I made
a shield and shouted this is sparta
whilst killing the wildlife it was a
good day day 22 I returned to the
villages I wanted to know how their crop
grew so fast whereas mine took forever
oh it's Walter of course its water so
off I went with my new knowledge after
stealing all of their crops again the
following day I made a bucket
iron is hard to come by in my world okay
but by the end of the day I finally
understood how to farm I also use my
shield today check this out I'm a badass
as we hit day 24 I decided to take more
care of my Hobbit house renovations
began in earnest I first made a storage
room it wasn't much
but I felt like I had big-boy brain I
even made corresponding signs ooh
day 25 I set myself a new task climb up
high and make a lighthouse just in case
I got lost again so far I've become lost
three times and wasted so much time
getting home again so no longer this
will happen all I have to do now is keep
an eye on the horizon and run towards my
erection day 26 arrived and went before
I even realized I was mining and
building like I was possessed I wanted
to find diamonds today it didn't happen
but that's okay day 27 I got lost again
it's becoming a nuisance now anyway I
watched the green testicle zombie
explode today I now understand why their
creepers sneaky little [ __ ] on day 28
I had given up on ever returning home on
the plus side I saw rainfall for the
first time I didn't know that was
possible in Minecraft so I frolicked and
forgot about having nowhere to live the
next day I saw snowfall and thunder and
lightning this was awesome to see also a
pack of zombie Mountaineers you don't
see those every day I loved all this but
I really started to miss my Hobbit house
now on day 30 all my luck was about to
change for the better
I spotted the makeshift Tower I built on
a high mountain top this was it I was a
home legit great feeling I know it's
only pixelated blocks but don't take
this moment away from me I'm home mama
when I entered my home I realized that
was mid-renovation
so the last five days were a complete
waste of time oh well back to work I
worked through the night on day 31 to
extend my hobbit home and let in more
light it's not much but I knew the
aesthetic I wanted sort of modern rustic
and natural all in one I mean come on I
live in a man cave just like in real
life now day 32 I stepped back and
looked at my masterpiece it is well it's
hideous I'm a complete failure to my
family
also my llamas vanished today I didn't
know disappearing pets was a thing
tami a Minecraft I never got to say
goodbye to Luke and Leia day 33 1/3 of
my way through my noob playthrough I'm
still renovating but my plans have
changed
I'm changing my door location this is
huge news I'm sure you'll agree on day
34 I finally figured out how to attract
fat pigs
apart from my girlfriend of course a
carrot I also
figured out that too much carrots equals
unwanted pregnancies biology class
didn't prepare me for this day but by
the end of the day they were safe in the
llama pen
I should probably rename this pen they
may ask questions day 35 I decided to
make a Giant Ladder just like the one in
Metal Gear Solid Snake Eater it's great
sadly my PC had a brain fart and I lost
all the footage it started recording
again
just after I died here it is recording
now on Day 36 I've died twice but I'm
still happy I don't know what the Green
XP bar is for yet and now it's at zero
again I couldn't care less honestly I
spend the day mining on dammy I forgot a
pickaxe punching blogs takes forever day
37 arrived just in time to witness a new
Minecraft block I'd never seen before
blue gold lapis lazuli who's she I
honestly thought I was seeing things I
hadn't taken a break in 444 minutes but
that's only seven and a half hours come
on there's a rocky numbers day 38 today
was a good day I found gold and then I
spotted green gold I checked it's
emerald day 36 was a great day to be not
dead day 39 Hey look I got lost again
don't worry I made it home on day 40 I
learned that water can break balls so I
put some at the foot of my Snake Eater
ladder by the way he's that game
reference too old I am a fully grown man
playing Minecraft when day 41 arrived I
noticed I forgot to turn the game off I
came back to my game dead he's a pro tip
saving eggs at your games
I also found a crystal head louse thing
today and as I'm the only thing that
causes rushes around here I eliminated
him oh and look red gold no idea what
this is for but I'm sure I'll figure it
out sometime on day 42 I went back to my
humble farm and improved my relationship
with the livestock then I grew my plot
of land without asking for permission
I created a chicken coop today I decided
to use the eggs I couldn't figure out
how to cook and just threw them at the
ground it worked surprisingly well one
chicken got away right away I was going
to murder it but instead I led it back
with seeds
I'm a legit farmer right now day 43 I
forgot to pause the game here's my farm
one day one day this will impress you
one day on day 44 I found a lava pit and
once again I went into big brain mode
pouring water on the flames to see what
happened cobblestone anticlimax I wasn't
put off I tried this the other way round
creating this monstrosity it son mine at
present but don't worry I knew what to
do day 45 arrived and I was so hyped to
try my brand-new gold pickaxe on the
black stone this was going to be epic
what the hell
fake gold rubbish I stood here all day
it won't break so instead I used the
gold pickaxe on the local stone it was
great so much faster than anything else
but this euphoria was short-lived a
piece of cheap as the night drew in I
noticed someone urinating on my land our
eyes met we knew there could be only one
I used my superior for night building
skills again to gain the high ground and
decapitate his block stealing face day
46 was a day on the farm creating a
larger plantation and once again rubbing
up with the farm animals these things
procreate quicker than your mom I also
hid the black stuff again nothing
happened on day 47 I finally got around
to building a staircase for my new door
it's not much but I'm proud of it the
very next day I went back to farming but
if you're a vegan close your eyes now
this was cutthroat farming don't judge
me I like burgers now in day 48 I
decided to go back to the local
villagers we hadn't spoken since that
early day and when I got there most had
left I panicked and caged in all the
people who hadn't run away yet you will
stay we will do business now check how
epic day 49 is I gave a dog a bone we
became the bestest friends in the whole
wide world on our way home we were
attacked by grey people is that racist
my [ __ ] is and I slayed them we were
repaid with a flag we placed it on our
wall to commemorate our first ever
victory bear creeper you piece of [ __ ]
day 50 I'm already sick of these dogs so
I made one a prison
and when I mean kennel kennel not a
prett certainly not a prison he's happy
in there well I think he's happy but
anyway look at the build it's looking
nice and lovely on day 51 I realized I
hadn't found a single diamond in 50 days
I was beyond annoyed and changed my
mining technique I dug straight down for
so so long I was finding diamonds today
whatever happened day 52 still no
diamonds I retract my previous statement
I spent today with the animals to feel
better about myself day 53 we are back
in the mines my will to live was
diminishing at this point but as day
broke on day 54 I stumbled across more
emeralds hang on a minute those are
diamonds look how happy I am
or maybe I'm having a fit maybe it's
both quick call an ambulance I spent the
whole of day 55 attempting to find my
way back home I think we've established
how terrible my sense of direction is
this plus the handful of diamonds I was
carrying led to the most tense I've ever
felt in Minecraft I made it back home so
I had no need to worry
I then crafted a diamond pickaxe and
sword and to make the occasion even more
special I also made almost a full set of
gold armor damn I look good day 56 I'm
in mining heaven this pickaxe makes
things so much easier 55 days of torture
are now worth it for this beast on day
57 I found this thing I stayed calm and
asked my discord if it was friend or foe
they said fall so I killed it and all
its children quick hide the evidence
I've changed so much since I found
diamonds what is this anyway it's slime
yuck day 58 in the mines I intended to
make more diamond pickaxes but
accidentally became sidetracked and made
a diamond chess piece I now look
ridiculous and now I'm completely out of
diamonds but don't worry I found more
Yolo damn it nobody says that anymore
the very next day the peer pressure to
match my armor became too much for me
and c3po Adam aru arrived oh my I look
good day 60 well looking back at the
footage the highlight was a fox getting
into my chicken enclosure and eating
every last one of them there must have
been around 100 in here on the plus side
we now have a fox then out of nowhere a
new enemy type shoulder and
in the party so I ran away on day 61 I
woke up and wanted vengeance for my
chicks the Fox got his comeuppance and I
decided to upgrade my farm to better
protect the animals the chicken pen was
revitalized too with these new recruits
I began to spiral down into madness by
day 62 the loss of my chicks hit me hard
I decided to make a glass fortress
around the animals I had no real idea
why oh and later that day I was calling
the local fox population and remembered
the black stuff in the water I quickly
used a diamond pickaxe and completed the
ice bucket challenge
obsidian I was so happy I then decided
to go back to my glass prison for my
animals on day 63 I liked this obsidian
so much I filled buckets of lava and
threw them in the water I now had enough
obsidian to make a portal well I thought
I did I've seen portals in other
people's videos but I've never really
paid attention to how they are
constructed so damn it this is going to
be a long trial please bear with me oh
well we can always go back to the prison
built hang on how did the creeper get in
there day 64 came and the glass prison
was complete I forgot why I made this oh
yeah yeah the foxes next time I'll be
prepared on day 65 the Raiders returned
again and with more numbers still no
match for my shield and reflective
Wonderwoman skills take that crime oh
okay too soon there are even more now I
took that flag it looks great on my
Hobbit house by the way I created a
storeroom in my old hallway for things I
smelted often it streamlined everything
I finally felt like I was becoming a
better player still a complete noob but
a little bit better day 66 in my first
ever playthrough of Minecraft I tried to
make a portal like I said I'd seen these
before so I had a little bit of a clue
what to do something to do with fire and
a big door
other than that I'm clueless and fYI I
experimented with this every few days I
won't include them in the video because
they're very boring and you don't want
to see a noob failing so many times
anyway if it comes to it I'll just
pretend that this is art on day 67 I
decided to make all the random things
I'd never made before the
were interesting as they allowed me to
create a bookshelf
I hoped something cool would happen here
it didn't then I had a stroke No then I
had a master stroke very different I
intended to take the random things I've
made and see if I could sell them to the
local villages and maybe even see them
use them change their professions I feel
like I've heard that before this was
going to be epic I was so optimistic and
when I got there a red bar began to fill
what the hell does that mean the
villagers were going insane with stress
I thought don't worry about it I shall
be your protector I've never failed in a
battle yet well I was wrong I was I was
wrong I was dead wrong unperturbed I ran
back in to gather my belongings and
fight the Horde
I won cuz I'm epic but hang on another
raid incoming I was doing ok
fighting gallantly but then this
happened I was run over by a bull I'm
not going to pretend this went very well
over the next three days we continue to
fight a total of 13 raids in a row I
died many many many times including once
the exact moment I respond by the way my
tactic was to open a door and offer 1 in
for a 1v1 and then beat the crap out of
them it was a good tactic but the ball
was impossible to fight oh I was
triggered I was so triggered every time
I won the fight another hard came to
battle every time I respond I died again
I decided to restart my game and here's
the thing when I restarted the game it
was day 69
but luckily the raids had ended but the
villagers were all dead rip the dream I
came back and it was a village of
Raiders my hopes to give the villagers
their new skills and professions were
shattered before I even had the chance
to start this was a horrible three days
in my first ever minecraft playthrough
but on the plus side I'd learned so much
about protecting villagers and maybe
building a wall to prevent those raids
in future day 70 I was feeling quite
reflective and spent the day mining I
started to use a strip mining method
deep in the ground I stuck to the level
where I first found a diamond although I
do enjoy spelunking more the strip mine
method is so much quicker
nets that green XP bar that I don't know
how to use yet the next day I met a
lanky black dude I was expecting to be
attacked but no he was fine with my
presence I was okay with him being here
too so we became bros I sort of regret
what I did to his real brother let's not
tell him when day 72 arrived I decided a
change was needed I hadn't moved away
from my home base for longer than a day
so I made a compass and decided to walk
in a straight line until I found
civilization I chose south well I think
itself I'm not completely sure how to
use a compass yes I got lost but look
what I found
on day 73 a village the smoke signal
caught my attention a great little
village with a raucous set of people who
liked this Bell I'd lost one community
before so I set to work right away my
plan was simple box in the inhabitants
whilst making a pen for the town to be
isolated within its boom it sounds like
the real world right now I worked
through the night cutting down any trees
that could hide the undead I took on
those zombies in the rain I was a man on
a mission
I also figured out how to turn the
zombies against each other this night
the undead now fight for me for a little
bit as sunrise rose on day 74 the fence
was almost complete and all trees were
gone this was going well a creeper tried
to ruin everything whilst I was crafting
away but I'm now a ninja and escaped
explosion I was feeling invincible I
allowed the villagers a little yard time
whilst I constructed more houses in this
quarantine zone that night I went back
to my idea from last week attempting to
give villagers career paths after
throwing down a smithing table this dude
immediately jumped out of bed to fulfill
his life's passion I was feeling good
right now and immediately set up a
smoker to see if anybody else wanted a
job they didn't day 75 in this noob
world everything in the village was set
up a farm a fence a thriving community
I felt happy enough to leave my new
family and venture back home I decided
to make a path all the way home I don't
know why I did this
I used a compass to get here so
theoretically I could just walk north
and it would lead me to my hobbit hole
and on day 76 I reached home making the
worst decision of my playthrough in the
process
Mining through a crevasse suddenly a
zombie child appeared I was helpless
what could I do
but things immediately got worse oh [ __ ]
I hate creepers
luckily getting back to my gear was
simple enough just follow the terrible
brick road I was looking forward to
grabbing that useless XP only seven
levels where's the rest
I finished the walkway which entered my
house by the failed obsidian portal and
the Snake Eater ladder for the rest of
the day I farmed I fed the animals hmm
things are getting a little too cozy in
here day 77 big brain moment I decided
to make a railroad to my villages I used
all my iron ingots to make these bad
boys it was epic and it was great until
momentum ended things or lack of
momentum I should say my dreams of
travelling to the outpost whilst going
to the loo in real life were over I knew
I had to fix this so I decided to
experiment experiment number one use
activator rails if you play Minecraft
you know this was a terrible decision
but if you've come to learn from my
mistakes here's one I jumped back in the
cart and raced towards the rails but
nothing happened after much deliberation
I created a lever to activate the rails
forgive my excitement here mastermind I
thought I jump back in my mine cart and
what the hell was that an electric shock
long story short activated rails were
not what I thought they were day 78 I
came back with a new plan
powered rails these must be the right
ones they were heavy on gold resources
but after three days of making this path
I needed to make this work placing down
the rails sporadically as I didn't have
many gold bars left and I also
remembered to use a lever to activate
them anyway
I said sail would the powered rails give
me a speed boost let's do this yes oh
yes science wins legitimately I felt
great figuring this out all on my own by
the day break of day 79 I was back in
the village with my people from now on
young man these will be called the
Village People this was also the day I
bought something from the smithy a
sharpened sword all glowing with
awesomeness I don't know how this is
done yet but my guess is the enchantment
tape
later that evening I was growing the
villages retail Plaza when night rolled
in six zombies somehow got inside the
villages quarantine area I had
absolutely no idea how day 80 I awoke to
the sound of whatever the hell these
things are in the sky my mission this
day was to befriend a cat I've seen a
few hanging around my first attempt with
cooked fish was completely futile or
maybe the problem was my inability to
attract [ __ ] just like in real life
that joke was totally too far my
apologies but later I tried again I
needed companionship and now I had raw
fish and it was surprisingly easy I made
a new friend and now for the last 20
days of this journey you will hear this
incessant meowing day 81 I spent the day
showing members of my real-life family
my minecraft railway they weren't
impressed but I don't care I love this
big on day 82 I started another project
I was determined to learn how to use
that portal and every attempt I'd made
so far was a failure so I built myself a
science room for all my testing I was
determined by day 100 I was going to the
Netherlands that's right isn't it the
next day the grey dudes returned don't
worry after this video I will definitely
find out what their real names are but
for now they're called the grey
Marauders I look forward to their
attacks because I really like their
flags now I wish I collected more
earlier so I'm going to start now now
it's day 84 I knocked down a nearby
mountain blocking the light from my
extension just look at this place I
wonder what I could do with another 100
days anyway I started marking out
another animal prison here is going to
be a kateri you know why on to day 86
and continuing to make obsidian for my
magic portal I came prepared with fire
in a bucket I walked down to the river
and this happened I know I'm a noob but
this looks broken to me right I spend
the rest of the day hitting obsidian box
for science I started thinking there
must be a better way to make obsidian
than this and by the way my next attempt
at making a portal that failed I failed
again
yeah the closest I got was setting fire
to obsidian the
knew I was an idiot but looking back now
I was actually really close to achieving
my goal
I made an obsidian machine in the early
hours of day 87 I thought I was on to
something by making water and fire flow
into one another
I failed yet again science is hard I
also set myself ablaze today in all the
panic I forgot I had water right next to
me
whoa I almost committed dead but don't
worry I'm okay
stop judging me cat I was in the mine
with that cat on day 88 I had a new way
of making obsidian but a moment came
when I saw my judgmental cat stood one
block above lava I thought to myself
what would happen if that cat touched
lava I tested the theory who's laughing
now cats later that day I developed this
technique to create obsidian Wow it felt
good that something finally went my way
it's been weeks man this stuff is hard
to mine though on date tonight I was
still attempting to make a portal this
time using lava
don't laugh at me I was rudely
interrupted by the grey Marauders
standing on my brand-new glass roof I
went on the warpath taking down their
general I then attempted to sleep to see
if the others would leave they do not
leave so on day 90 the battle continued
as long as it doesn't say raid on the
screen I'm pretty confident in these
battles after victory I put up another
banner to further infuriate the
intruders I went back inside to work on
my portal only to notice everything was
on fire I panicked for a while but then
I put the fire out with an axe as we all
do
I noticed the hole left behind was my
original mining back from day one
there's something poignant here so I
bricked it all up because nostalgia is
for the weak day 90 I was back on the
farm I noticed that every time I needed
to think I went back to the mindless
work on the field and in the animal
prison my captives enjoyed my company
too I think they may have Stockholm
Syndrome in fact you have Stockholm
Syndrome if you're still watching this
after 90 days and yeah I took a
screenshot of the animals it's father
bank if you know what I mean day 91 is a
Eureka day
you finally figured it out I made a
portal I stood there and admired it for
hours I jumped straight in to go to the
Netherlands hang on is my my bottles
broken we'll come back to that soon I
decided to go check on my second attempt
at keeping villages alive I jumped on
the train my in real life toilet breaks
have been so productive when I arrived
back things took a turn for the worse a
raid began the one thing I truly fear in
Minecraft this will be a never-ending
cycle that kills off my beloved
community or can I fight to survive I
quickly turned the difficulty down to
normal instead of hard because I'm that
kind of guy the first three waves were
all manageable but the fourth wave my
progress halted and once again it was
because of those oversized bulldozers it
took less than two seconds to kill me I
hate those things
so I hatched a plan to drop lava on the
Beast it went horribly wrong now
everything is on fire but I've learned
how to save myself from doing this
before the Beast didn't know it's the
first time he's been on fire so I won
the battle the raid is now over it's not
more there's more and now I have no
fence off my life after setting myself
on fire again the hordes were inside my
compound I tried to fight back but I was
completely overwhelmed yet again and
then I awoke I was trapped in a box room
with Jason boys I fought hard my only
weapon was seed for some reason and
there was only one possible outcome the
next life I continued this fight and
actually succeeded and then gradually
won the war No More Raiders this fight
lasted over three days again it's now
day 93 suddenly the raid was called off
my guess is there a time limit that's
reached because I couldn't kill him
quick enough but hey it wasn't 13 this
time so let's look at the positives I
grabbed as many planners as I could and
put them on display through the night of
day 94 I rebuilt the village that fire
damage took its toll and then something
clicked I finally understood how
professions work in fortnight I feel
like I'm only just learning the basic
mechanics right now and my 100 days are
almost over I was in reflective mood
again and took the train home to try
final few things before my time was
on day 95 I ventured back into the
original village the one that was
pillaged and ransacked by the Marauders
and when I got there all the Marauders
had moved on the town was eerily silent
I found a survivor the one guy I managed
to block in his home is still here and
willing to do business even though he's
lost everything and everyone he knows
day 96 I set myself one final task the
last thing I would construct in my 100
days but when I ascended there were too
many enemies so I went to sleep instead
morning broke on day 97 let's get
building can you guess what I'm going to
construct I had to keep climbing down to
ground level and climbing back up again
to get a view of everything which made
the construction time much longer on day
98 we're so close to getting this
finished there's a little bit more it's
worth it I promise
day 99 arrived and just as the Sun set
on my final full night it was ready
ladies and gentlemen may I introduce Hut
watch minecraft edition proudly sitting
above my original Hobbit house a symbol
of my tough times and all the things
we've achieved if you're still here now
thanks for coming on this journey with
me I hope it's been entertaining here we
go our final day day 100 I took one last
look at my home and ventured into the
nether how would my journey end see for
yourself
well now that's one way to end a video
thanks for watching please write 200 in
the comments if you'd like to see a
second episode if you've been here for
the full episode thank you so much it's
been emotional I'm Adam the Minecraft
noob see you next time
[Music]